hello I'm Danny McGuire Andy Behrens
here I do you I've got the game for you
welcome to GameSpot plays today we're
playing hatred look at this guy he's
pointing a gun directly at us the crazy
son of a [ __ ]
games coming out on Steam next week it's
not couple down on gog.com because of
all the controversy surrounding it video
games we haven swimming on Twitch we
can't even streaming on Twitch because
they're such a massive pack of [ __ ]
it doesn't matter he runs GameSpot we're
adults we're gonna show it so here we go
this is a this is hecho I've played a
little bit earlier on I'm gonna start a
new game skip the tutorial because we
know what's up yeah we're gamers we're
comment and hit it on hard mode so this
is a easiest way of describing this game
as it is a isometric MUP I guess almost
a twin stick shooter it is I'm playing
on the our can on an Xbox 360 pad here
on that on PC and this does have mouse
and keyboard support though as well
which I've used for its turn this up
though whose name is not important see
steam on its carcass is Jack hold bitter
hatred too much that's not one night did
Leigha pretty medal cognizes the time of
vengeance and no life is worth saving
this house on fire right now are we as
many as I can
anything get a rowdy 5/8 knife so the
tutorial starts with his basement and
then this is the first level I'm you
just rated straight up murder fools
so I'm controlling with the left stick
and shooting with the white trigger all
these people that one are I hate that
mechanic here though is you regain your
help we do these cinematic executions
yeah hey why for executing you you get
these you get these sweet death
animations and that's what forget your
life up yeah you know this is what
creates the controversy that's that's
what yeah so that's what it said in the
in the in the one of the loading screens
I said that's the only way he can heal
yeah it's like hitting people people the
hate flow through them and it's pure
pure job and so he's right stick
turnaround move with the left stick if
you hit the left trigger it was kind of
a hotline miami style den dosed endo so
this is on the controller its extended
to the edge of the screen which is kind
of a bit weird on the mouse you've got a
lot more movement with the with the
extender i feel and you've got grenades
as well we'll get to - I got ya how to
shoot - no you go inside someone's house
let's do it
we better kick the door open I guess oh
yeah you can kick people really far in
this game this is kind of a bit you know
I'm realistic watch this I'm gonna kick
this lady kick her you hit the door off
door into the PICU as well take all your
family come here I'll kick you and then
execute you yeah the purification yes
sorry there's one liners in this game
I'd say there's there's quite a lot of
them I don't know if this game is taking
itself seriously or not but they're kind
of hilariously crap yeah I am which I
kind of a bet they're not yeah maybe I
hope so yeah yeah that's definitely
funny there's one stage of which here he
says welcome to nightmare after he'd
shot a dude in the head that's what
we're doing it so our current objective
here is to kill the populace the
populace 43 of the populace are
remaining and this is next level kill
the daughter look at all these people
eventually the cops go yeah so I mean
you're playing this kind of just to get
the controls down because what fun is
it's a suitable weapon understand people
that don't get back no no that's true
and eventually they do like yeah
gentlemen friends yeah but even so even
so think I'm amazing
shoot him there were huge phrase destiny
well what about destiny yeah well this
book Lee that's and he's saying let's go
play destiny it's yeah probably better
miss that's probably what drove him
insane he got he just couldn't get that
last 2/3 play so I've got a bunch more
weapons here obviously this is the intro
level so they're being pretty easy I'm
difficulty stuff we're gonna play it
teaching you the basic yeah I'm moving
around and I kind of like the like the
aesthetic is actually kind of rad and I
like we'll get to it later with the
explosions oh I didn't I was about to
say like we were kind of everyone was
expecting this game to be made by
amateurs yeah it is it is it's like
slang studio yeah it's actually promise
technically technically yeah yeah it's
kind of you know rougher edges a little
bit but it's good
well what gets it when we get some of
this the bigger explosion if I mean I
played I played a lot of home where to
the city of gangsters in the similar
style and
plays way back this is basically like I
know people who are freaking out about
the controversy why not like this is
basically poster one like it's yeah came
out 1997 it was an isometric game where
you play as opposed to office worker who
goes crazy and you basically you
complete levels by shooting armed
combatants like that's how you completed
each level and so in a minion way you
know it's not actually a doctor similar
except they have these little audio bits
but people are like no kill me and I
straight up stabbed him in the head yeah
I like math not it's you know it's just
one of my shooting dudes and let's go to
the I'm really grocery store was good
fun we went to before in fact actually
here's the fair market you can get into
certain cars
yeah it's unexpected yeah I guess maybe
they show doesn't tell you but yeah I
didn't I wasn't expecting it anyway so
we should probably go and see if we can
find a car yeah the area is pretty big
as well we didn't see any of this the
last time I played No and you can just
rate of call people are kind of cowering
their houses in their houses and then
here you go pie like this guy who's not
cowering at all just hanging out
you're not afraid it should be okay I
got a gun a K says otherwise
look it up frame ready stop there but
and that's about it it's not price on
this yet on Steam I don't know how much
good selling it for
some of the executions that was an
execution there some of them were just
done kind of little bit fast yeah and
let me try it some of the other where I
don't have any ammo and the other
weapons and I think why do I show off
you're pissed I see the map of the
bottom corner it's got like grocery
store it's got a cocktail we've got the
truth
let's take in the bar let's go to the
grocery store first I will check out the
bar after that and see yeah I've met the
people that the bar really easy to kill
pretty wasted part of the hit the ad
with the pistol and I do like the here
we are and we're just going having a
little shop sorry folks
this is what was the rob said earlier
tonight we'll clean up all oh yeah I
want some cops to turn up though that's
what's gonna get that fun here we are
here we are are coppers
execute this guy kicking the face and
then get into the car which is props the
most fun I've seen in this game so far
I'm just kidding with you
somebody's good in I want know the cars
on fire already oh she's gotta get it
that's a sure sign of things to blow up
and so that was a bit of a pain because
the actual net throw grenade here
because the as controllers were actually
done there by like the same as the
regular controllers like left stick was
just move around yeah so wasn't like
there's no accelerator no there was no
accelerator wasn't labeled like that
no tank controls yeah part of me still
remember saying postal back in 97 I'm
not actually had tank control god man I
gotta get killed here dude you better
execute someone that are execute this
guy yeah oh sorry Ben oh really it's all
the way human shields man that's all it
is dammit why weren't you like maybe
some people still alive in the in here I
can just run in and execute some of you
jerks why did you all have to die on me
man
jerk you should have use non-lethal
bullets just in case I get it okay
here's this guy here
that's what these guys I think I'm gonna
kill him see good you know we'll play
hard mode this is one of three
difficulty modes god damnit die oh oh
[ __ ] grenade
did you throw I think I might have just
thrown a grenade on myself that's the
ultimate hatred hey self face yes
absolutely
recent one one life you I think you're
gonna spawn at the sewer here oh really
yeah yeah oh yeah
the respawns are the sewers then yeah so
we did see at the end of the first level
there they do alludes to the sewers
being the method of that transportation
I didn't start with much bloody health
or to that much died there's a dog I
accept my drop it killed him alright
let's go to the bar you pre executed too
early so maybe the only encouraged new
driver cop cars I think there any cars
that drove maybe are any cop cars
actually yeah I think the parked cars
you cannot G chased I'll just break into
any car that kill people yeah but let's
go to this bar probably what are we to
go that was unexpected what a way to go
I guess the town got revenge on you I
know alright let's try it again
how do you think the mainstream press
are gonna enjoy this bad boy well the
gaming press gotta jumped on it already
that's true and so considering is
basically just like I had it's not even
that bad well yeah it's just kind of
dumb innocent like this is this is fun a
gnarly like three yeah but it's coming
I I kind of wonder why I got an a Oh
I guess because there is I'm kind of
thinking the same thing so like a bunch
of like like which won't let you stream
it because it's at all totally right I
think it's like well here we go here we
go get it to the top boy good guy and I
guess the co essence of doing it no AO
is 13 euros or whatever those fees
that's dumb I don't know wow this is a
lot of this yeah this is weird actually
it's like controlling inhale oh I'm not
sure it's a great weird I'm like
pressing up on the left stick to drive
and then control your speed by
feathering the stick yeah but it's kind
of weird I think I preferred on the most
this is one of the cooler parts though
is that
yeah the physics and stuff like you can
straight up just in the sound they get
this sign maybe get a part of that
[Laughter]
earlier on him I'm gonna shoot through a
wall with a bullet oh god Donna maybe
that's a drift into it you know who
cares my side
yeah about signs when you can just
straight
[Laughter]
can even do this in GTA Express Lanes
twin car and I kind of like this it's
like like I like you I appreciate the
level of dumb that they're kind of the
lowering room structure here in fact I
don't cheat a 1s I mean yeah look I
think you can straight-up drive into
certain as well oh yeah I'm like
definitely could it's fine I'm just
gonna tell the metal here hello
look at this guy's having teeth watching
TV and then suddenly this cop cards man
now that's the way to do it yeah this is
this I kind of into the the
monochromatic you can really see the
cops coming oh here's the bar oh they're
all just hanging out so how does this go
oh this is what ends the party Oh get
out get out
oh and they say no party started and
they say video games aren't hard how
many people are about to kill pop over
here innate opener a grenade I did how
many more people do I have to kill
that's they're just the real question
right here 15 exterminate does it say
police isn't popular ma'am police apart
well we could go to the police station
if you want
I'm trying I should probably get an
execution of the truck or lady sorry
well you aren't hard move it please not
to do properly
maybe it's not as easy well what's in
there just like that although let's go
yeah hey what's up guys oh you heard
there was a shooting happening
yeah come investigate without any weapon
Oh killing time has a good one whoa how
come well general populace is heavily
well your arms yeah cuz this is in a
state not in America they don't have a
conceal law this game is actually a
commentary on what would happen it was
saying take our guns away
this guy's homes look at I just even
bother giving it you don't even bother
shootin why I'm wasting bullets gonna
stop him on the head look at that Grim
Reaper thing in the bottom corner kind
of interested not and the bottom left is
a grim reaper sign oh like it's like a
can I go to the cemetery in a second
that you Domino that's the Sons of
Anarchy were to get hang on
I'm gonna kill you all that's right man
I'm not gonna kill you all I'm only
gonna kill the premier he's got real
good another nine oh here we go okay I
actually was looking for a cop car so
thanks a lot guys
really appreciate it as far as I know
there's no lock on that it kicks pretty
wide range oh okay that's that's got to
be pretty self-aware but a white male
wearing a black coat here black stripe
through the [ __ ] is that they're
built houses like the EC man this is
like this is like some Arrested
Development's model home [ __ ] oh no
that's not good get out get out of cars
a saucer oh yeah these must be a you
know she's on the American built cars
come here in there it's not that I'll
tell you what the there isn't what
satisfaction in the actual like one like
once you've done it a few times yeah
yeah the executions are kind of whatever
maybe they get more varied later but in
terms of the actual ballistics of
shooting and the feedback like one of
the things I guess at Princeton is like
an uncertainty game but like just saying
I guess any Princeton's is a game to
Rivet bungee reading her head to nail
like feedback on like shooting people
like shooting a head and almost like
ether sprays out the top and yaksa noise
and the impact of it hitting the person
you're hitting and like in this it kind
of you don't really get that I guess
they're maybe not with these weapons
props it changes up there on there's got
to be I mean we've only played this for
shoes like maybe an hour now it's yep
are you already feeling like the
repetition of having to do the execution
is just I feel like oh that's only way
your hair dude I like the way that's
it's short I like the way that the
animation is relatively short but I want
to fit like Oh funeral procession oh the
irony that is okay this game itself Oh
doesn't matter cuz I got my respawn and
annihilate all right let's annihilate
this funeral procession and nights you
know man
focus my funerals that's what are you
having a fever of night idiots wow that
was easy
don't worry cops I'm just murdering this
this innocent bison I got an achievement
for that I just gave this up steam
achievements right zip those trading
cards that's all those hot hatred
trading cards that ago all right so once
you've killed everyone in the police
station this is level 2 you go down the
sewer like a ninja turtle
[Music]
baby is this bebop and rocksteady I'll
kill ya
alright god this is way harder get our
wait a little sooner just drop kicking
everyone well you can't you can't take
these guys out with drop kick yeah their
armament yeah can i ex give you at least
it's one of the many ways in the game
anymore
not particularly realism ik alright
let's keep going
alright so can you explode that little
red skate ramp super sharp yeah friends
grenade this gate robber no no I need it
what's that where is the right kind of
stairs a few of them there's like one
yeah oh yeah
oh holy barrels it's a video game the
physics and the explosions are
accomplished pretty good I guess
super unrealistic like this chunks of
just concrete coming off but like it's
it's kind of rough it's cool to at least
see something happens reactors we're
gonna make our way around the sewers
consumer they were gonna kill a lot of
homeless people down here or extreme
after washing
this whole thing oh yeah sorry yeah
right sorry we hang up the super oh that
was an execution so was i Joe isn't you
mo in your juice mustard us does it um
uh oh I don't know actually
yeah I'm trying to see if it does have a
look there that doesn't unquote I'm
conflicted I'm gonna lure these guys
over here oh yeah
eat it hold on probably connects to him
though there's also - hit the fire
across the sidewalk
do it hey some guy they don't tell you
his name renting to get the star much
like in the vein of postal hatred dude
or whatever now you can you can vault
over stuff as well by you running yeah
just a lot more linear and guided than
the previous level yeah I wouldn't mind
if life lesson
it's got a
whoa you see this you throw that into
like don't know right it's either that
or flew at me all right so it's getting
that fun handit's and he was the
controller so we swapped - that's the
keyboard you didn't think it's way more
reactive they can relay the player
it just means you can actually like any
point where you're shooting people
because it's kind of hard to see a lot
of this game I don't know what exactly
where exactly your dude is because your
what your your eye line is drifting to
where your crosshairs is okay so it's
kind of hard to remember where it like
here I don't where the [ __ ] is they do
like I don't know like I'm not even
looking at that part of the screen so
like your line of sight might be
obscured for the shot and you're trying
to see the guy yeah exactly
so I think the Mexican
fit appointed to do
although Kenny watch this gun not on
that much time shopping rain yeah even
real no.5 dude yeah here we go
fire fire
he's gonna go down go down and stay down
all right I'll meet down to lay down
yeah oh man a river in the Schmidt dad I
ain't done ain't a river all right let's
see if we can get through this level
yeah seeing through doorways and stuff
it's not exactly the most intuitive
process these guys it's been a park by
one coming down a zip line to your debt
execute all these dudes health pack eat
your greens finally according to the
waypoints I have to trouble up there to
the north what do you think okay this is
the problem problem I think a lot of
people have this game is that there are
mass shootings in America yes and that
kind of making light of them maybe
that's true but the you know as Call of
Duty making light of all the wars that
America goes off so it's on its soil I
think it's hard to call the kettle black
on this game yeah it's a little bit you
know kind of have to
if you want your game is like I'm people
are free to criticize this game for what
it's doing but like also you know but
it's coming but I've worked you're
playing yeah it's it's the cops treat
bag of challenges
like I was the reason like I think the
reason I think it's dumb that they do
that stuff is because it's just it's
lazy like PR right like it's like y'all
like Yeti you're making you're gonna
make that game like the mainstream press
know a little to report on and it's
gonna get like controversy and oh my god
James your [ __ ] bad and then were
suddenly having the same conversation we
were having twenty years ago when
everything else yeah well I call them my
happened and suddenly it I get
everything else was getting dragged into
the mix there and it's just kind of
sucks for video games so like all in all
this game isn't really I wouldn't say it
but the question is it like do you find
this game enjoyable
something what we're about an hour so
far like it's alright like it's kinda
repetitive like I like this type of game
I like poster one yeah how I'm in I like
the poster do I love papaya me like I
thought I managed to nine it's an
ongoing plan it's probably hired no
critic David yeah I'd like to cut the
game but like kind of getting a little
bit repetitive what I'm interested in is
where the story aspect of it goes like
does the games they seem almost similar
enough that it could say something
interesting perhaps maybe it goes into
like I like mechanically they like to
stuff what the cars is kind of funny
like if they keep adding levels of
gameplay like dot onto it I think then
it could be pretty interesting or could
be hold my attention and but the most
part it's it's a Wednesday they're kind
of shooter II thing I don't you know the
gore isn't actually like it's not
exactly not that gratuitous I don't know
like you know the way like after a
couple of hours of playing Mortal Kombat
you still find the fatalities
hilariously gross
yeah like even these aren't this isn't
really hilarious because this is just
kind of like it's actually kind of thing
and even in poster where you can like
postal 2 is a game where you know it's
definitely not taking itself as like
seriously as this
the shooting of innocent civilians we're
posting to the game where you can kiss
the people games that takes it to
another yeah that's kind of a little bit
more [ __ ] up messed up that mouth off
no alright let's leave it there that's a
that's that's enough for today
and you don't to get all your hatred Aoi
I don't go I need to keep a little bit
of hatred for the workplace and you
Batman thanks very much for joining with
you and we're gonna have a review of
hatred up on games with the Olympic
Games bit gamespot.com
and next week hopefully for the release
of the game on Tuesday it's available on
Steam we don't know how much it costs as
a PC only uh yeah house I know I don't
think Sony or Microsoft they want to
pick this one up huh going anywhere near
this one seems alright I don't know
probably gets a liver repetitive I
thought that that I can see myself
paying through that first area a [ __ ]
like trying to master it and like
crashing through the grocery store was
fun I feel like I could do a better job
at killing everyone in that party yeah
oh yeah
it's a video game so that's hatred thank
you very much for joining us today on
game saw place and stay tuned game spot
calm for
continuous coverage of hatred and other
video games that don't involve killing
innocent civilians and something to do
like splatoon
you